um it was it was it was awesome I mean
they were really actually really nice
and very like when they came to us they
were very straightforward and really
like gave me a lot of confidence in
their in their sincerity and their
willingness to go and do good things so
it was I was very excited by and
obviously it was you know life changing
in terms of what kind of freedom it
would give me going forward financially
and otherwise but the I was it was a
very good thing it you know once once we
got there and and you saw some of the
internal politics it was a different
story but yeah
Nutella was a software that allowed
people who ran it on their computers to
connect to other people who run the
software and once you're connected you
would be connected to sort of like
what's the best expression you'd be
connected so that the people around you
and who are then connected to other
people and so you would have a horizon
of people who you could try to remember
what the feature said originally was but
you could talk to them and you could
search whatever files they wouldn't make
available and transfer files with them
and what was unique about this was that
it was a system that allowed people to
connect directly to each other and as a
result find other people and find data
that way without having any company or
central server in the middle of it so
there'd be no no one would control it it
would just be sort of a free way to
connect to other people and Napster was
very successful at that point and they
had apparently they had a great deal of
computer hardware just dedicated to
letting everyone connect to them and it
was a big expensive operation for them
to do so this was a very simple little
bit like it when I was designing it it
was very much in my mind that it wasn't
going to function perfectly like you
would never be able to talk to everyone
else on these networks it would always
be like you could just talk to the
people nearest you but it was something
that you could do and it's exciting
because it was software that created
something much larger out of little bits
of software and didn't require actually
any physical hardware or any any service
to set up it was just software that
connected people
well I think the biggest problem they
had is that we didn't really ask them
about it it was more at and it's just as
well that we didn't I mean I'm sure if
we had they would have they would have
said that it's a bad idea you know we
really should look at this and you know
to their credit they're probably right
if you're a big big corporation like
them that's not what you need to be
doing your job is more how do you
monetize people rather than how do you
enable people to do things they want to
do
no i think i think i probably wouldn't
do it again in the same way but you know
I i think what ended up happening was
fine and and i think it was only good
for pretty much everyone involved like
it didn't look good for AOL but it did
it end up hurting them did not move the
needle at all like they were I think
they denounced the time warner merger at
that point and so they were doing what
they were doing that was that